rando pays vous propose cette semaine
une randonnée hors des sentiers battus à
la découverte de l'île et fleurs jaunes
à cilaos le long de la rabine coin
rendez-vous à cilaos direction il est à
cordes après avoir dépassé le départ du
sentier du theil bits et la rabine
gaubert garez-vous un virage plus loin à
côté de la ravine coin notre
accompagnateur du jour jérôme turpin dàm
réunion nous emmène sur un sentier non
référencés qui n'apparaît même pas sur
les cartes mais qui permet de rallier un
il est abandonné il est de fleurs jeunes
pour s'y rendre il faut monter en plein
vent par le long de la rivière coin une
ascension raid est difficile de cordes
ont même été installés dans la première
partie pour aider à se hisser
l'avantagé d'un sentier sauvage c'est
que l'on petit observé facilement les
espèces comme c'est pas tang qui
n'hésite pas à se poser sur la paroi en
face de nous d'autres curiosités sont
encore plus proches de nous comme ce
bois de fer batte à nous on l'appelle
boîte fait avatar parce que bon il
pousse à ras du sol comparé aux vrais
bois de fer qui est un dandy et ça a été
utilisé à l'époque pour faire des pièges
aux oiseaux donc les graines cassez ont
récupéré le latex et latex en mélangeait
enveloppe de l'air émulsionner ça
donnait une colle à oiseaux qu'on
mettait sur des bronches et les les gens
elle mettait cette colle naturelle est
bon pour coller les oiseaux quoi bon
maintenant c'est terminé on le fait plus
que tout est protégé on mettait en cage
notamment le maire l'un le martin
lévesque rose et c'était plus un objet
de décoration
plus un amusement que 1 mais gastronomie
moi même j'ai mangé des oiseaux faut le
dire c'est bon mais envoyons par exemple
je prends un
intertek je suis désolé mais bon le
teltec pialet plus me reste plus
beaucoup quoi donc cet hommage d'aller
chasser ces oiseaux là pour manger alors
que c'est rien le teltec est endémique
vaut mieux le protéger que le manger
à mesure que l'on monte la vue se dégage
sur cilaos mais aussi sur le rond de
bras rouge et la crête des salazes
la route en contrebas semble déjà loin
et au dessus de nos têtes le ballet des
papes en continu qui sont en pleine
période nuptiale est en fait les montées
les piques et c'est pour prouver leurs
techniques de chasse qui peuvent chasser
qui peuvent nourrir les nourrissons à la
naissance doit donc si on regarde bien
il monte et replongeant plongée et hop
vous regardez au dessus vous avez le mal
où la femelle qui en dessous ou vice
versa là on voit il ya 2 il ya deux
mâles et une femelle les deux se battent
donc à ceux qui adorent le mieux pour
apprendre la femelle
même s'il est peu connu ce sentier reste
très praticable il est en effet
fréquemment entretenue par des groupes
de camionneurs qui l'empruntent pour
redescendre la rabine coin en canyoning
un parcours de plus de 200 m de dénivelé
avec des rappels allant jusqu'à 25
mètres
même si les canards ne vont pas plus
haut la suite du sentier reste bien
tracée en crète l'a vu se dégage à
nouveau et cette fois ci on distingue
aussi par au progresse le sentier du
taïbit là on a un super plan le super à
sentiers là qui monte jusqu'au col du
taïbit et si on regarde bien on voit
trois plateaux le premier plateau qu'on
voit c'est le plateau des salazes le
deuxième plateau là juste en face de
nous c'est le plateau qui mène à la
broche vert bouteille et le plateau tout
en haut c'est là le plateau de la plaine
des fraises c'est le dernier plateau
avant d'arriver au col du taïbit et la
rivière qui sépare entre nous et le
sentier du col du taïbit tu sais le la
rivière de gaubert c'est un dépôt de
camions aussi
une fois la montée terminer une petite
descente sous les mains ouvert la rabine
fleurs jaunes permet d'atteindre le
plateau avec un splendide point de vue
sur le piton fleurs jeunes
en progressant sur ce plateau on ne
distingue aucune ruines de l'ancienne il
est seule la présence d'espèces
exotiques permet d'imaginer qu'il a un
jour été habitée par des esclaves
marrons des eucalyptus mais surtout de
magnifiques spécimens de chaîne les
seuls de l'île avec ceux du plateau des
chèvres
des arbres insolite sur notre île qui
contribuent à faire de ce lieu un havre
de paix bucolique bercé par la rivière
en contrebas qui ravira tous les
randonneurs et m'en sortir des sentiers
battus
sur cette rando ce que j'aime c'est
l'isolément isolement du site quand on
est sur le sentier il ya personne soit
sentiers et puis on a pas mal de choses
à voir notamment on a vu les papangues
ça sur des sentiers à la réunion faut
quand même un chercher assez loin pour
trouver des papes en faire des parades
nuptiales comme ça sans être craintif à
se laisser voir le sentier raid info
faut le dire le sentier raid avec des
grosses marches des gros dénivelé
n'importe qui peut venir mais avoir
quand même un minimum de condition
physique pour arriver jusqu'au plateau
du late fleuve jaune là où on est actuel
il est fortement recommandé
conseiller on va dire fortement
conseillé de prendre un guide local a
pour vous emmener parce que la trace
n'est pas vraiment indiqué donc faut
vraiment connaître où on va le but ce
sentier on arrive à lille est flou
jeunes faut savoir c'était un il est
longtemps entretenu un donc pas les
esclaves marrons faut savoir que lille
est flou jeunes n'est pas très loin de
l'île est peut-être calme donc qui dit
ap calvi esclaves marrons il est fleurs
jaunes des esclaves marrons forcément si
on fait des recherches on est presque
sûr de trouver des vestiges de l'ancien
temps de l'avent l'opposition d'
esclavage ici dans ce secteur